welcome to this video playing my way one
of the frequent opponents IAM he's
always playing we had line of the search
he's always worse to losing yes playing
this all the time and i forget to look
it up this is really crazy this is
really just bad for white he always has
a totally bad position and he repeats
the line and I don't punish it because I
forget to look it up it's it's really
crazy yeah we had this on the board a
number of times already check okay um
bishop f2 or Knight f6 wasn't so great
yeah maybe just take this and there were
no reason not to really I just give the
check okay let's not think about this so
long all the time um what about there's
no direct way to punish him right now if
I take take it says some way not to take
it trying to keep the the Queen's on
probably not yet ok so is at least a bit
a bit tied down push up the two maybe
okay i don't know i don't know it's
equal material so i don't want to fall
super far behind on the clock IAM by
trying to refute this mmm and i really
need to look it up I really need to do
that it's sick how often you played this
against me and I keep forgetting how to
refuted
yeah ok I want to trade off the bishops
if he plays Bishop e3 ago Roxy one and
this looks tricky if I'm in terms of
development so I wonder why is not just
taking only three what alternative is
there Bishop d3 really looks look
strange to me I would I thought that
there is only this move maybe yeah or
maybe you can go Bishop g3 know and
didn't do it at the end so let's just
develop him I don't want to get the rook
tractor awesome but okay I can maybe
play against the F on the F porn ism is
a weakness here h5 and age 5 h for loop
g8 does this type of this type of setup
group g3 I don't know Bishop everyone
maybe root g one I can take h three now
I have root g five yes getting this pawn
I hope
so Luke is a bit strangely placed but I
hope that it's not getting lost or
anything kinky too kinky 223 or
something hmm maybe how do i do a play
this year then the look is a problem I
wonder about ninety seventy five maybe
if I should do that and maybe maybe get
the 925
okay now he's just trading wait not so
good okay get this to e5 okay this is
somewhat somewhat problematic rook
position as now is now solved the H porn
is still a bit weak of course but I have
a counter play against the g2 whisper
should probably cancel each other out 94
to c5 probably the sister idea should I
play c5 maybe here maybe just try to
control this and try to control the
night yeah I get night night to e4
Knight to g5 this this kind of thing
let's go here controlling e-form 94 I
should have played 94 of course but ok I
can still do that and go go here
93 there's some tactic here cannot take
I can play d 5 maybe this is ok just the
tech attack the the bishop now to h5
maybe so that I can take ok I go all the
way back time warning no I know I don't
have any time
looks looks really good now but he said
he's a tricky player I know that
yeah you can maybe run all the way there
maybe I should cover this for the moment
97's all just check made right h4 is
hanging I know really why did I allow
that
check now come on this is this is just
just winning now right
check check check check check check mate
whoever tense game yeah really tense
game I keep forgetting this bloody
opening line and it's a it's totally
crazy that he repeats it all the time
check I always seem to have dragged as
well yeah 95 I really know Bishop e3 is
winning straight away yeah there are
tricks like that yeah Queen III rupee 8
I mean this is really looking terrible
white is playing it all the time and I
don't refute it okay Bishop e3 would
have would have one immediately and yeah
this is this is stolen Jack still
playable form and white yeah but should
be three is not ideal but I want to
wanted a similar position and here it
was okay step by step I went to to to
get at the at the pawn Knight ed5 was
strong okay attending this room okay
yeah that's strong really strong okay
now I gotta go I've gotten the pawn but
I have this this slightly awkward rook
so it's not easy to to play in a
practical game but here here I'm okay
and just plus 1 year with some technical
difficulties but at the end I I managed
then I managed to to blunder this this
is bloody h-bomb here to our c4 check c4
check and wins hmm that's easy actually
check and winning yeah that's much
easier but ok yeah I mean this is
winning as well but it's it's it's it's
trickier one day ever had a checkmate so
care but it does not seem to be and now
of course not this but 95 just
preventing the the night move that's
much easier and here it gets tricky
again yeah might be five though just
know it's not winning for black yeah
okay we both had 20 something second so
not to do critical about that okay
thanks for watching